Yeah,
they certainly voted cover,
they exist since 2000 years and they
have a very strong message,
uh,
but
they don't deserve to recover soon
unless they really accept the guilt that
some individuals loaded on themselves
and the institution has to learn that
perhaps the conditions under which
priests work are conducive to certain
misbehavior.
So maybe the conditions will have to be
changed.
This has been the case,
a indeed so close reformation by Martin
Luther and others at that time.
The Catholic Church was it in a much
worse state of affairs,
much with much more guilt in that sense.
Then today,
and it has a kind of led to a
purification.
Uh,
the challenge from the reformation from
the reformation has led the Catholics to
learn,
but from luther and others.
So now they are almost
undistinguishable.